I would like to start my talks with a
photo of the audience everyone can wave
excitedly about what they're about to
see yay okay thank you that is all I all
I ask of you
other than listening hello I'm Paul Paul
Tarzan I am at stripe right now for the
last three years working on the sorbet
compiler before this I was at Facebook
for five years worked on HHV M and hack
and before that I did my masters at
Stanford hello everybody I'm min tree
I'm also working at stripe now before
this together as Martin and irska we
have been working on project called
dotty now it's known that this project
will become ska 3 and we're excited here
to present our work in Ruby okey doke I
will start with the intros and hopefully
this will be useful ok so we are at
stripe has anyone heard of stripe yeah
okay Wow that's phenomenal I'm so
excited every time we give a talk
there's more hands which is wonderful
so we're platform for payments we're in
25 countries then the nice statistic we
released yesterday actually it was 84%
of people have used stripe in the u.s.
last year so thank you all for having
paid for things on the internet and if
you're running an internet business
please look us up and the the exemplary
stripe comm slash jobs why we're sent
out here ok I we both work on developer
productivity this is our pillar inside
the company and it is a large dedicated
team that does a lot of different stuff
and we do testing and code hosting and
reviews developer environments all the
abstractions that people build on the
tools that we are basically responsible
if you're having a bad time at stripe it
is our fault so we're entirely there to
try to make everyone's life a little bit
better specifically we're on the Ruby
side of stripe so I want to talk about
our Ruby usage at the company so it is
our primary programming language we did
avoid getting on the rails train so
there is a little bit less magic in our
Ruby than the normal people feel we have
a very enforced subset of Ruby we do
love lint rules lint rules are one of my
favourite things in life
so there is a lot of them our product
code is in a mono repo this is
intentional we are going them on a repo
route we're not splitting that out about
ten macro services and a few satellite
services around the edges but we try to
agglomerate a lot more you know points
of leverage are a nice thing to have and
most of our code goes into an existing
service we're not trying to get on the
trendy micro service train we are trying
to keep keep this stuff together here's
our scale of the company just to give
you an idea of what we were working with
before we started the the type checker
the sorbet type checker
so we've millions of lines of code
hundreds of engineers and they're
producing thousands of commits per day
okay so this is kind of a like medium
sized good development org that we had
to start with and hopefully make it
better we did not invent type checking
of course we were standing on the
shoulders of lots of giants so Jeff
foster at the University of Maryland has
been doing type checking in Ruby for
like ten years now d ruby was their
first P ruby ruby dust all of these are
basically the same thing just different
evolutions and we took a lot of
inspiration and a lot of work from Jeff
so thank you very much for that also
github started a unreleased project that
they were also doing type checking since
they're using a lot of Ruby and we we
collaborated with them using the parser
we use a share parser between the two of
us which is very nice for them to let us
use that so definitely didn't go this
alone we're very happy that other people
have been contributing to the Ruby
type-checking world question we're
always getting now are we open source we
are not unfortunately yet we if we want
to first prove it out internally we want
to prove that our codebase can scale and
can ship a gradual type system on top of
a such a dynamic languages Ruby
internally and then we're gonna give it
out to the community so we we are trying
to push on this we are launching it and
using it internally I'll show you stats
on it after that but it will be coming
soon to you if you are a large company
that
is using Ruby yourselves please send us
an email we are happy to collaborate
early on in the development we would
love to chat about that but I do not
like I've jumped very quickly I do not
like vaporware announcements of course
so there is a online demo if you go do
sorbet dot run in any any of your
devices of choice you can see our type
checker in action so we took our type
checker compiled it to web assembly and
is it running in your browser so type
some Ruby code in there and see what it
does and see if you like the type system
okay I'm gonna talk about the
development how we built this type type
checker right so wewe assume everyone in
the audience is a PhD in type theory so
the interesting parts to you are going
to be the practical parts of how we
deployed this and how we implemented it
at the company so we're gonna dive
through some of that as as part of our
talk so we sent a big kickoff email at
the beginning this is only full text
here for people that are gonna gonna
look at it and pause the video later but
I want to emphasize a few things so we
send out an email to the whole company
that says we are going to eliminate
whole classes of errors right a type
checkers job is just to find all method
method method missing errors and just
get rid of them we we have noticed that
this is successful in other languages
right my PI and Python has added this on
hack on PHP has added this on typescript
and flow have added it to JavaScript
right this has been done before we
aren't we aren't blazing trails so
hopefully that do you risks it a little
bit this makes us much easier to keep
our code a living breathing entity we
believe very strongly that that code
shouldn't atrophy and shouldn't rot you
should be able to make holistic code
changes and migrate your API s and push
everything forward and without a type
system it's it's a little dangerous to
touch every line of code at the company
so we we want to be a lot more confident
in our code mods as we're pushing these
through we
think that if you write down your types
you think a little more carefully about
your interfaces right so instead of just
like I have a function that takes three
parameters and the third ones optional
and it might be a hash but if the second
one's a string the third one is now an
integer might not be the interface that
you were trying to expose so hopefully
you think about that little bit before
and also it makes code more readable
right if you can see your interfaces and
know what you're doing you can you can
do that so we emphasize this strongly to
the company got a lot of smiles and nods
as we sent out the email so we plowed
forward with the project here was our
timeline so just 50 weeks ago we sent
out that email and then we dov'è into
two separate teams one there was three
people on the project we were pushing
Dmitry myself and Nelson who isn't
present right now he's on vacation so
we'll allow it so I took trying RTL at
the company seeing if we can use RTL as
our type system we don't have to build
something that would be fabulous you
know use something else that exists and
then Dimitri Nelson took off on the
prototypes see if like this is a viable
solution if building a type checker in
C++ will actually work for Ruby we gave
ourselves a month to see what happens
and we decided yes the C floss class is
gonna work we are gonna be able to build
the type checker easily
well maybe not easily but like usefully
in C++ and we're gonna dive down on it
so oh wow let's click here double clicks
quite often so I'm gonna dive into the
type syntax portion where we were
debating and deciding about syntax and
maybe give you some insights if you're
gonna follow similar projects so we
built a runtime type system before this
it was great it was similar to like
contracts where you like to define a
contract above the method and then the
method has to abide by that contract so
it was all written in Ruby people were
able to see it and see what it does
there's no magic well sort of magical
but it was all at least in Ruby and
5,000 signatures were made it by made by
users while during this period
oh man I am a disaster with this clicker
okay we did have one learning though
syntax changes are okay so we originally
designed the very first one there you'll
see this was our way of defining type
signatures we wrote standard method and
it takes two parameters two hashes the
first hash is a has the keys as the
names of the parameters and the types as
their values and then the second hash
has a bag of whatever specifically this
is the return types so this was our
first incantation it was it was
interesting and useful we started with
it but because we're in a mono repo we
just just up and decided all right a
builder syntax will be much easier for
people to use we designed it and just
did a big code mod and changed all of
the signatures into the builder syntax
it's nice to be to be in a mono repo so
we switch to that and then we started
noticing that there's a lot of problems
with you know pre declaring things
integer and string have to have both
been loaded at the time of the the type
signatures definition so we just
recently moved to a lazy loading
signature right so you pass it a proc or
a lambda instead so you don't have to
actually preload all your classes so
we've gone through lots of evolutions of
our syntax I think I think I only
highlighted three of the seven we
actually did but I do suggest like don't
bike shed like crazy on your syntax get
something out there and make it flexible
enough that you can change it going
forward here are some of our rejected
syntaxes which I like syntheses which I
like to throw up some of my favorites
were monkey-patching an or operator onto
integer so you can make some some union
types between integer and string we
debated having this like callable tea
thing that you wrap types in some of
this was a little off there were the
bottom one completely breaks Ruby syntax
that that would have been that we'd have
to write our own parsers and break all
the tool chain and everything all the
awfulness that comes with that
so we debated all of these and shied
away from them but just wanted to show
you some examples of things we thought
of okay now we're going to move on to
the type system portion of our timeline
and I'm going to hand
over to my colleague Demetri everybody
so when we went on designing the type
systems we started with principles what
do you want our type system to be and
I'll Drive you through all them the
first one is we wanted it to be explicit
we built we wha will believe that
there's a space for writing type
annotations and we believe there are
areas where they're valuable if you're
discussing your the earth if you're
describing your interface there is a lot
of value in writing down your intention
so that people can read it in a big free
/ I like ours with a lot of developers
they spend a lot of time reading
existing code and integrating with
diseases exist in api's we optimize a
lot for readability the second one was
we wanted it to feel useful instead of
feeling burdensome this means that while
we want you to write the type signatures
when they're useful sometimes they're
not for example if you're inside the
method itself we can do type inference
for you very easily and it's your
internal interface is your internal API
your don't expose it to anybody so no
need to do a lot of typing there that's
sad if you do want to extract types you
can do this in the second example here
with seed outlet you can specify that
don't do type inference here I wanted to
have a string specifically yep the next
one is we wanted to have a simple type
system simple but still able to model
the Ruby that we're modeling we started
with a nominal gradual type system which
was good start and we'll quickly edit
Union and intersection types because we
needed to model country flow and local
type inference so that people can be
typing the last types when they don't
want to quite fast we needed to start
modeling the standard library and Molina
standard library grew generic classes
and generics methods some of the methods
in the standard library have weird
signatures like the method could that
clones objects so we needed self types
and I said before we have the static and
runtime type type system that both
implemented we wanted it to scale in
multiple ways we
big teams and we want so that the tool
can be used by while collaborating in
the team we also want it to be it easier
to use across multiple dozens of teams
who read code of each other who you use
different abstractions between each
other so we emphasize a lot of read
ability and our code base is big and
only getting bigger so it's very
important for the tool to be fast and to
encourage keeping the complexity
isolated behind your interfaces and at
the same time because we have a limited
amount of engineering life we wanted the
development to be up to a point not
postponing hard decisions so that we can
achieve fast ok some of the numbers
performance wise we have a huge monetary
people who have million lines of codes
we want the tool to run on every
keystroke which means it has to be fast
so currently it's around 100k lines per
second per CPU core and it scales more
or less linearly up to 64 cores we
didn't try after 64 cores I just for
comparison this is how it compares with
some of the tools in the area Java C is
a Java compiler robocop is a standard
linting tool for Ruby which we use to
enforce a limited subset the good thing
about robocop is it can run per file
it's entirely syntactic while we have to
run the entire code base yes the next
one which is very important for us is
compatible with Ruby we wanted to first
of all be able to share this tool
outside of stripe and this means it has
to be Ruby we can't change the syntax
who can change the evaluation rules we
can't change the parser we can't patch
through Ruby runtime at the same time
we're already have a lot of internal
tools we have ID ease we have linters we
have various kind of refactoring tools
we want them to still work and if we
were to break syntax they will start
randomly breaking - and the next one is
given that we're big company different
teams are doing different stuff at every
point some of them aren't ready to adopt
the type system yet because they're
working hard to shape a feature or shape
a product it means that different teams
will be doubling a different pace
it also means
that some teams may decide to never
adopt it because they're always in
prototyping state they always
discovering what's a new thing and they
want to be moving fast and they don't
actually know what's the type signature
of their thing because they don't even
know what it does in the first place
so because of this will have some levels
of strictness first of all the basic
level of strictness which just makes
sure that this is valid Ruby like your
file should parse as the next one is you
enable type checking which means we'll
start given the types that we already
have for example for standard library
we'll start checking that you use them
correctly for example if we can infer
that you're operating in an array from
implantation of our functions we'll be
able to check all the culinary's so you
jumped all bark on an array the next one
is type strict type strict requires you
to type your interface so that if
somebody is using you they get check
they get to be checked this is intended
to be used but for the internal
interfaces which you expose to other
developers at stripe this is how you
teach other developers how to use your
API this is how you make sure that they
use it correctly and don't blame you for
the fact that they misused it and the
last one is type strong this is you can
not only have n type functions you
cannot also have type values inside your
functions which more or less means we're
not gradual anymore all the things have
to be ascribed types all the things have
to be checked you're more or less a Java
level of saving us here okay the next
one why do we have run type type
checking and can we ever get rid of it
because the teams can adopt at a
different pace or never you will always
have untyped files consider this example
we have a file the disk defines a
function called foo which declared
declares that it takes an integer and
returns a void and you have another file
which is not typed and cause it with a
string this is an incorrect call because
it's passing a string to a plate that
expects an integer the problem here is
that if the foo method was to try to
protect himself from this by like
testing whether per argument that it got
as an INT is not an integer will
complain about it because we'll say that
your test is always false you get an
integer why do you test it so if you
were to try to protect yourself from
somebody passing your string will
complain that your protection code is
that code which means we have to have
one tied back system because otherwise
there is no way you can protect yourself
yep so just to be clear the type system
is the runtime type system as Aaron is
intended there to stay for as long as
was first see for now maybe it will
change in the future for now we don't
see it changing now back to the timeline
where we decide the type system we
started type checking some code manually
we we're the first users of our own tool
where we choose a show the specific part
of the code base we're starting typing
it and seeing how it works we got we
enjoyed the process and we started
thinking what does reload quickly so
what do we mean by rollout which shows a
few metrics which is getting more people
to use our type checker get in more
files to be type checked and getting
more call sites in those files to be
type checked because given that to a
gradual type system you can have an
obvious typing where's it say everything
is untyped everything is unchecked
you're done okay so now we want to do
all the things got more stuff typed so
how did we go in this well we wanted
typed all the things now that's not how
it works
there are three of us there are million
lines of code people are writing more
code per day that it can we can type
check manually we can't go and stick
everything manually so reality is when
it tools we need tools that will help
must multiply our effort and we've built
a few tools for us I'll present you a
few tools that we've built so the first
four in order to introduce the first one
I need to talk more about what Ruby does
which is also very similar to what was
presented about dart in the previous
talk in Ruby you can define new methods
and runtimes for classes that are not
aware of is this function takes a claw
and injects a method into it this
specific snippet adds a method called
favorite number into an integer which
are transferred to do type checking a
language which does this is hard because
the basic thing that you wanted to do is
type check in this figure out whether
methods exist in the first place
so do you can type check them and we
have a huge repo we have the huge number
of amount of code that already does this
and we depend on libraries that do this
so how do we go about this well what we
did is we made those definitions from
being dynamic to static we build a tool
that loads all the code in Ruby so
that's the runtime processes it and then
runs via reflection and serializes all
the methods that it believes exist in
London so with that we can see all the
metaprogramming everything that would
cool was controlled by magic we see
everything we also load everything by
our type checker
we also serialize it then we have those
two representations and would div that
we see the things which are seen by
static type checker and we see the
things which are not seen by static type
checker and we can generate a ruby file
from this which describes the things
that we don't see so that we see
everything we do this both for our
internal code which does metaprogramming
and moodle's for our libraries our
internal code sense has something like
200k lines of meta programming generated
code from this and the libraries has
around 700 cave this allowed Astor law
are allowed the tool before we had to
support all meta programming we do
aspire to support more of it but we
don't didn't want to block on complete
support we're supporting more and more
of it over time but we're also
eliminating some of it from as we go but
this allowed us to roll out before this
is done so we don't have to chase the
tail the next one is as you type stuff
you find bugs some of the box are common
like for example there is a lot of
implicit assumptions about what's
nillable and what's not which is
implicitly encoded in your logic like
you know that if I'm in this branch it's
never now
but you never tested it so the most
common thing that we have to do when
type-checking files is insert explicit
nail checks we'll build a function for
this and we've automated it our type
checker can insert checks for you we do
this for a lot of classes of bugs which
are very common we can make implicit
checks explicit we can make common box
be checked and run time and modify this
in the source next the important thing
for us after we did this over entire
code base
if tufa is to fight okay what did start
type checking so we also build a tool
which tells you in the current code base
which what's already type checkable if
you were to ask this file to be type
checked would it succeed and after you
do this well it would be nice to have
this file actually have something better
than intact and in order to do this when
you need to find a way to prioritize
what do we type first so we built one
more tool that finds the methods type in
which will enable typing the most stuff
consider this example I call foo then
you call bar in it then you call bass on
it in order to type check calls to bar
and bass you first have to type check
foo this is a precondition because there
otherwise don't know the receiver so
we'll build a tool that's able to find
the most impactful things to type so
that we don't need to type everything
and we know what are the things we
should concentrate our effort on and
while we find what the types it will be
also nice to not type it manually so
we'll build it to a little tool that all
the subjects will type signature to
right it's actually still using the old
syntax because we're in process of
migration so given a method it guesses
the type of your arguments it guess it's
a type of your return type it might be
imprecise in particular because your
methods can have bugs because it didn't
check all for all I can like corner
cases but it gives you something to
start with yep so building all those
tools made it possible for us to roll
out and that's the timeline of roll out
so I'll transfer to Paul to cover it
all right next next to me tree okay I'll
swap yeah okay so now I'm gonna talk
about the actual deployment of this all
this was pre deployment right we had we
built all these tools we built all these
cigs we started burning things in but we
didn't have a blocking CI job that like
told people you must type check before
you you know before you pass so the
canonical the canonical answer to this
is we have to change the car tires while
the car is driving right we cannot pause
all product development finding this
video was amazing by the way this is
actually a you should just look this one
up quite phenomenal okay how did we how
do we actually roll this out we had a
60-day dark launch period so we had a
period where we were running the job in
CI on every push but it didn't tell
anyone right it just told us so it
pinged us in the slack channel it told
us you know what branches were failing
what error messages they were spewing
and then we could coordinate with each
other saying hey why I'm taking a look
at this right now I see we broke the
type checker I see there's an incorrect
sig that works at runtime and the static
type checker doesn't see it so we were
able to coordinate for about two months
in this dark format until we felt
confident enough that we were being
pinged so seldomly that we are ready to
give it out to everyone else also
interestingly master branch failures we
treated a lot more prominently than
anyone elses branch failures because
they could be doing whatever they want
as we found out like people commit code
that doesn't parse and that doesn't like
anything and it alerted us so master
failures all right find those ones
you're probably type-check branches
where we didn't want to get pinged in
the middle of the night when we rolled
out we put this preamble on the top of
every type checker failure okay so we we
have a big thing that says hey the Ruby
type checker found a possible error in
your code if you believe this errors of
false positive or confusing please come
to our slack Channel and talk to us
right there's there's an avenue to to
get some feedback and get some help we
get you know this is used heavily
every day there is a way to run the type
checker locally heads up you could have
you could have saved yourself the two
minutes of the CI turnaround if you had
just run these commands and then also if
you really don't want type checking if
you want this thing to go away here's
how to make it go away right so we give
people a place to come get help a way to
get it get the feedback faster and a way
to get out of type checking if they
don't want it and this preamble has been
very successful we we see all three of
these used every time it is important to
give an escape hatch in both directions
okay so if you want static type checking
but you don't want it at runtime say
it's a performance critical method or
like the runtime semantics just don't
matte like there's a bug in there
runtime and you want to get your code
out while we fix the bug in the runtime
you can have a checked false on your on
your Builder similarly if you just want
runtime type checking and this weird
sorbets static thing just tell it to go
away
we have an unsafe operator that you can
just wrap around your thing and
everything from there on the static type
checker will let happen so giving escape
hatches in both directions we found very
very useful to our to our engineers and
these are used in the code base as
Dimitri said before we had two major met
method
two major metrics that we were pushing
ourselves on so the amount of typed
files and the percent of method calls
which we know the the the method
definition on so we went from zero typed
files because we just invented it to 70
percent in three months right so there
was a very strong period where we were
able to just get the type into the files
and say hey these already type checked
we're good to go the largest thing we
did to get that number up was to group
our error messages by type right so we
noticed like oh my gosh if if we added a
type signature to this one thing we
would be able to type a thousand more
files or ooh the standard library
actually does return nil there we should
go fix our standard library definition
and then we'll be able to type this file
because it's middle similarly the
percent of method calls that we were
trying to increase we built a bunch of
punch lists as Dimitri was showing dealt
a bunch of tools to give us what to go
and type
we got about 25% we started at about 25%
of the calls were known because we took
our D ELLs standard library definitions
and ported them to our syntax so just
the standard library is about a quarter
of our code so that's that was super
great to start with and then just you
know working through the top of the list
and working our way down has got us to
about half of the code or half of the
call sites are known to us in the static
world so again
grouping them by what made the
transition from typed knowledge into the
untyped world gave us a lot of a lot of
leverage of what to type graphs are fun
uh I was I was putting on this
presentation and my boss walked by says
that looks like a thumbs up is what our
our graph was we actually just broke the
metrics for a couple days up at the top
where we weren't noticing things is
untie pible but that's will remove the
thumbs-up at some point so this was
basically how our typed rollout went so
we started off with a bunch of people
thinking their files were type checked
so they like putting typed true in their
files and they thought it was all
working but like sorbet wasn't running
in CI so it wasn't checking anything so
we launched and had to untie a bunch of
files that like literally didn't type
check and then we slowly put a bunch of
the type checking back into the files
right so the orange area there is the
things that could have been type checked
by our metrics and then we just slowly
burned in the things that could have
been type checked you'll notice there is
like still monotonic increasing a little
bit so it's our users are helping as
we're going which is very very nice to
to be helped by your users similarly our
second metric is is the amount of call
sites that we know are our type check
and then know the type of and this was
every vertical bar is basically us
hitting through some large API you know
adding it to our internal ORM or adding
typing to some crazy DSL that everybody
uses so that's that's us jumping
ourselves up on the typed nosov methods
and then the the gradual slope of the
lines is our users adding types to their
to their stuff as they're going on
we were similarly we had broken our
metric here as well you can tell we're
excellent metric engineers but we wanted
to know how much of this effort is done
by us and how much is done by our users
we wanted to make sure our users were
actually getting value and not just us
like sitting over in the corner being
excited about typing and no one else is
doing anything with type-checking but it
turns out that that as we were rolling
out our users were adding hundreds and
hundreds of type signatures per day to
their code so we were adding hopefully
value to their world over there and
while we ourselves were typing the core
abstractions so that was the roll out I
want to talk about some practical
experience we learned while doing the
type checking rollout
these are some some interesting bugs
that we found in our existing code when
we added types right so if you're uh if
you're a Python developer a PHP
developer you you know that you know
random dot R and we'll return if it's
greater than 0.5 it'll you can assign a
variable otherwise you can assign
something else whoops but I clearly
can't click anymore
but in Ruby you write it similarly at
the bottom most people will like check
things for truthiness the problem is a
lot of people assume that the integer 0
is false e but in Ruby the integer 0 is
true the-- the only policy things are
false and nil those are the only falsey
things so if you do this if statement
here this is real code this we will
notice that oh that's it always a true C
check what are you doing why should you
have something in your else branch so
we're able to tell you like hey you know
get out of your Python mindset and
truthiness is not how you supposed to
check so supposed to write at the top
way oftentimes error checking code error
handling code is untested right you're
like you don't write your unit tests to
catch your error statement you write
your happy path unit test right but if
there's you think like oh this is a this
is clearly a way that we can you know
rescue are correct exception but that is
not the exception your
to be rescuing right it's it's not parse
error it's parser error and if that
thing is never thrown from you never
give it invalid JSON or something you
never get the catch statement and you
never get to run that so the fact that
we know that there is literally nothing
in the code base called parse error we
can tell you that you're you're
referencing a class that doesn't exist
we give you a little helpful suggestion
of did you mean
similarly maybe you're coding too much
Python as as our examples always have
and this is maybe how you think you
raise an exception in Ruby right it
makes sense you raise the thing and it
takes a constructor argument but you
like you can't call classes in Ruby you
have to new them up right so here we say
that that you can't just call that
method we think you're calling a method
called argument error here you're not
newing up a class so you forgot the dot
new right after that so my old syntax
things like this we can very much notice
and the static world that you didn't
have to write runtime behavior for the
most common thing we found was nil
errors right so if a user loads
something and then immediately does
something with it and without checking
whether the load failed in between that
you know should have been checked you
will get a no method error found on your
on your nil class so we we notice a lot
of these we tell you what the types are
we say hey we thought you wanted to pass
this type but instead it wanted a non
nillable type and you passed it a
nillable type so you must remove the nil
somehow you must check if it was no and
an error out or you must call t dot must
or somehow you got to remove the Milnes
before you get going this is what it
this is what it looks like in a you know
well typed nil check because we have
control flow dependence typing you're
able to if if you checked the nil nests
of it and bail out and returned like a
bottom type from that point we know that
that branch is dead and the other branch
is non mail so this is this is what we
correct people too
this is this is probably my favorite bug
I found in this people thought that this
syntax is how you can do to when clauses
right if you just or the two things
together that's a good that this
actually is a pretty good syntax I like
this one but unfortunately this is not
how Ruby works and they were just oaring
to random things together and checking
it if that's the value that you were
doing in your case statement so I
separated those two and we we were now
checking for refunds and charges so when
we were launching these are some of the
user feedback that we got internally we
were trying to name the project and one
of the name suggestions was developer
happiness
very proud of that name that one of our
users gave us but it seems to be a lot
of the folks are getting value from it
at stripe a lot of the folks are seeing
it's not burdensome they only add types
when they need them and when they want
them and when they add them they do get
commiserate value for what they're
putting it so some user testimonials
hopefully that that people are seeing
value in our type checking we are not
done with our work as you saw we're only
70% of the files and about half of the
call sites so we want to ship all those
numbers up into the right before we head
out into the open source world but at
least the the derivative is good the
directionality that we're finding inside
the company is useful so a big glance
back at the timeline we started off with
the project kickoff tried others things
off they worked prototype did in C++
decided if that was feasible or not
decided yes we're gonna plow ahead
invented some syntax came up with some
semantics coded our code ourselves in
our first little like attempt
we got a sister team involved we said
hey developer tools you are friends can
you type some of your code and they did
and give us a lot of great feedback on
the on the feedback loop we got some
external folks from outside our
organization we're like hey now we're
ready if anyone wants to be an alpha
user try it out see see how it works
got some feedback they're forced it on
everyone in a roll out after some some
dark launching then now we're working on
impact
full type-checking right find the most
important functions and type check those
we're building an IDE integration using
LSP so that whatever IDE you want to
work in you can get some autocorrect so
you can get some type of heads or you
know you get the feedback right in your
editor beauty of IDs we are guessing the
types of things as Dmitri pointed out so
we are telling you what we think your
return type will be maybe you might want
to burn this again or what your
parameter types are gonna be we are
working on de magic in the code base
right we showed you those you know a
million lines of Ruby code that the type
checker does not see but the methods
exist at run time so we want to remove
some of the magic from those things so
that we can actually see it in in sorbet
in the type checker and then we're going
to ship the thing open-source and
hopefully the Ruby community can use
this this tool to do their stuff so with
that thank you very much I appreciate
your time
[Applause]